he wants to put MSNBC on trial for
treason so that he can execute us Rachel
matow Rachel mattow who has lied about
everything over the last couple years
Trump being a Nazi she lied about coid
vaccines election interference I mean
she has lied about everything watch what
she does here this is exactly what you
just laid out Melissa they accuse you of
doing everything they are doing or have
done check this out the Republican party
right now has to make a decision and
it's their decision to make we have
party processes for a reason but
ultimately you listen to what Trump is
saying you don't just sort of regard him
as a um as a spectacle but you listen to
what he's saying yeah he's basically
portraying a future for America if he is
put back in the White House in which we
don't have another election after
because the elections are all rigged
that the Democratic process can't be
trusted that Congress should just work
for him the justice department should
just work for him that's a strongman
form of government that's not he
canceled the news like the news are done
that he wants to put MSNBC on trial for
treason so that he can execute us I mean
this is and he will put Rudy Giuliani on
the Supreme Court if he makes it that
long sure yeah I mean it is that the
Republican party is if they're going to
elevate somebody like that to represent
their party in a in a general election
not only do we have a 50-50 shot of him
being back in the White House any major
party nominee has a 50 party a 50% shot
but the Republican party will have to
reckon with that for the till the end of
time in terms of what they did to this
country wow everything she said I mean
she spent four years claiming that Trump
was an illegitimate president all of the
coid stuff everything else by the way I
think Rudy actually would be quite a
good Supreme Court Judge I don't think
anyone's really well I can't say anyone
I certainly don't think uh that his uh
legal mind uh is not worthy of that uh
James I surpr I suspect again this
doesn't surprise you the behavior this
is it it's baked into their ideology
right yeah well the iron law of
projection never of woke projection
never misses the it's an iron law they
always tell you what their intentions
are it's one of the best charistics to
guess what they have up their sleeve and
Rachel mattow should have just scared
the crap out of virtually everybody in
the country that understands that
they're telling you what their plans are
when they project them onto their
enemy